I learned how to sell on Wall Street and
in my view you know you can writing or
directing or whatever that's half of it
being really topped on your craft and
being excited about and so forth that's
half of it if you can't sell whatever it
is your script or whatever it is you're
going to be the best unknown you know
scriptwriter out there so it's sort of a
I don't like the idea of sales I don't
like salesman I don't really consider
myself a Salesman I don't like it when I
go into a store and somebody's like all
this very solicitous and this will look
great on you I don't buy it typically
and turned off by the concept of sales
but that said hey you need to do it in a
Hollywood my experience you have to go
into a room and pitch the out of
your script or whatever yourself is a
director or whatever it is and be if you
are genuinely passionate about what it
is that you're selling it's really not
it doesn't be a bad thing and it's it
gets conveyed in your delivery so that
was a really helpful thing for me in
terms of Wall Street naturally I'm not a
Salesman type I'd rather just be like
okay don't buy it i don't care you know
keeping that theme there so many people
they make these amazing films and they
say oh we're going to get this festival
screening and they do and they had this
great sort of party atmosphere with it
and then the film is finished it's
screened various festivals and now comes
the distribution portion of it and i
think a lot of people hit a brick wall
and the movie just sits there if it
doesn't get a certain deal and they've
invested not only money but so much time
and energy and hope into this film
what's your advice for people that they
say well i'm an artist i'm not a sales
person I'm not a business person tough
you know like okay then go be an
artist but don't expect to get a
distribution deal necessarily or don't
expect to sell a script or whatever I
mean it's it's just part of the deal you
can be that sort of i'm an artist kind
of guy and do or grow and just DIY it
that's cool do it you know nowadays you
can do that from beginning to end you
don't need to get into bed with somebody
a distributor or whatever it is but
you know it's just part of in terms of
the bigger picture and Hollywood inspect
stuff and studios and you just have to
do it and you know get used to it I mean
it doesn't have to be a such terrible
thing either it's not like you're
selling some stupid thing that you don't
like really you're selling your movie
you know right it shouldn't be it's not
such an ugly endeavor right so what's
your advice for someone that let's
suppose they are and that artists
mindset and you're like look you have to
be a salesperson you have to wear that
hat can you give them sort of like this
bulletproof excuse me a bullet point i
should say list of what they should do
to market themselves in their film what
kind of like morning afternoon evening
they should have in terms of like
structuring their time you know it's
kind of off topic but it but it's
something occurred to me recently it may
sort of answer your question indirectly
i'm really started our screenplay
competition a couple weeks ago and i've
gotten quite a few scripts and some of
them were very clear in the guidelines
and rules and so forth what we want it
needs to be typical screenplay format
it's not they're pretty straightforward
rules or guidelines and I've gotten a
few scripts we've all gotten a few
scripts that are formatted correctly or
their spelling errors on page one oh wow
okay and I'm so bewildered by it if you
can't take the time to assign a spell
check sometimes like there's one I'm
thinking of we got last week that they
misspelled they meant to type face and
they typed fade instead so spellcheck
didn't catch it but you know that's the
kind of stuff where I'm just like you
this is your thing that you have toiled
over and you're so Pat presumably really
passionate about this is your poured
your guts into this thing and you're
trying to get it out there how can this
happen like those sort of basic things
so I would just say you know make sure
your product is is bulletproof and and
then I just really feel like if you are
genuine about
your excitement about the project it's
going to be conveyed when you're trying
to sell it that said you might have to
accept the fact that I've written
scripts for example that I was really
passionate about and I've had my manager
for so and so on and producers say it's
not commercial and i could just be like
well them but you know what me
because they're right you know so so
that's something you just have to accept
and you can sort of say to yourself ok
i'm going to you know it's better to do
to find the stuff out before you make a
movie certainly or at least before you
write a script sort of what the market
is looking for I'm not necessarily
saying you know you should co-opted your
own vision and that kind of thing
depends kind of what you want to do if
you want to be a DIY and D filmmaker and
you sort of go it alone and you you're
not beholden to the industry and
people's tastes and stuff like that
you're still going to have to sell it
down the road but the short answer your
question is I feel if I'm passionate
about something if a person's passionate
about something they'll convey it I mean
that said there are people who are just
genuinely you know they're not they're
kind of shut down personalities and
they're not go Gary asst so forth so
then I guess my advice would be you know
link up with someone who is who's who
wants to be on board with you and can be
your sort of point man or woman and deal
with that kind of stuff sometimes it can
be a sales agent but typically i think
it should just be somebody who's on
board part of it part of the crew yeah
you